now that brings me to my smart glasses
and the final thought the president's
critics on the left and right are
lambasted him for wading into the NFL's
disrespect for the star-spangled banner
they say the protest isn't a big deal
that it's not worth the president's
attention as a rule
nobody has ever honestly insisted that
quote it isn't a big deal
whenever they say that you can bet it's
a big deal the flag is a symbol of the
country and it is perfectly within the
scope of the president's rhetorical
responsibilities to stand up against
those who attack the country itself but
his critics insist
it isn't seemly for a president to wade
into these cultural issues the country
they say has never been wealthier never
more economically prosperous but that's
precisely the point the country's
troubles at this moment are not
primarily economic their cultural
America did not elect Donald Trump
because he offered the most free-market
tax policies he didn't we did not elect
Donald Trump because he promised to
finally address entitlement reform and
write the country's fiscal ship he
explicitly did not promise that we
elected Donald Trump because he is a
singular cultural figure who echoed not
just the words of Ronald Reagan but the
wish of Patriots horrified to see Barack
Obama apologize for the greatest freest
most charitable nation in the history of
the world who hoped to make America
great again the culture is rightly at
the fore of most Americans minds and we
elected a culture warrior to beat back
the destructive anti-american barbarians
to restore a culture of gratitude for
the country that has given us and the
rest of the world so much and asked so
little in return now more than ever
despite the constant negative press
coffe FA
I am Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show come back tomorrow we'll do
it all again
[Music]
[Music]